okay for those who are joining the lists
livestream we've already been doing some
livestream software design reviews today
this is another one this one's about
software engineering tools and we are
doing in the late stages of documenting
the first thing we're going to do is is
finish our remote run remote run process
which are doing SSH like operations and
then we will be turning to system
processes which is doing PS like
operations
so I hope and believe that what we have
to do at the beginning here is really
really straightforward
so I think we rewrote these already
write remote authorization caching do we
document that yeah we made a page for it
I maybe we should open it just to make
sure we finished
looks reasonable to me
don't know why it's not showing up as a
link here ok so the main point here is
just that these things are now
implemented is that correct yep that's
correct I have added all these changes
some of them a few pieces might not have
made it into the last prototype build ok
so I have to look at this in prototype
bills all right well yeah you can change
her to like some of the extra options to
remote run process haven't made it in
there yet okay but so remote connect for
example I should be able to just do
remote connect and if I had a Wolfram
script it will work using um and I think
remote connect works in 11:3 is that
right there yeah you don't need external
fur just do it any sort of remote
connect in a remote run process ok so if
I say remote run process here so I'm
going to a host and my host is PI and my
process would be my thing will be LS and
then what I should get magnificent
great
Jamaica theta
why
give me the login again well that's what
the option is for right if you want to
do the remote authorization caching to
true one time it will ill cache it but
it still expects why is it going login
again why is it asking me to login again
it shouldn't be you know what you know
what's happening the data set is dynamic
oh okay
that's not good we could take a look at
in well that was very weird what just
happened there so if I say remote
authorization caching is it in this
built apparently not okay that's the
point of that that will catch that
authorization and anger you're good to
go
yeah data set this better that idea in
this we should take that out what's
gonna keep messing you up well yeah I
mean it's going to it this is this is
really messing this up okay and what
should we do with this in general I mean
the look I wonder whether this remote
login screen should have a thing that
allows you to remember me allows that
has a Remember Me button on it and it's
the only way for us to get that flow to
work so has an authentication dialog but
what we could do is somehow set that go
ahead tell me tell me what like the
concern was in order to get I could
remember me button there we would want
to save the user name and password and
okay imagine any keychain exactly but
some of the keychain stuff remember me
for this session okay that would work if
we can get the flow to work correctly
from that back to things so it said well
what about just having a checkbox that
basically sets that option to true when
it's you know well that's what I'm
suggesting yeah yeah if that's different
okay Garrett but like it would just
basically you know force that option to
true right and right and then you know
then you're good to go
um so I shouldn't that sorry
did we knit these and do we need to do
this nothing right now
um we knitted a little bit I don't think
we finished what Paige has done
I'm checking around oh yeah we did do
some of this right remote okay I mean
this was really close to done in the
last meeting so yeah I think this is
really you just wanted to see it one
more time in you know because okay well
so I'm seeing it one more time so does
this point to cloud connect by the way
no why doesn't the count point to Cloud
Connect that seems like a very relevant
thing for it to point to and socket
connect which i think is an obscure the
cards
what are functions attending connects
and see service connects yes that's
another one that's relevant I why is
socket connect even I don't think
run-through is in the slightest bit
relevant here I think remote run is
relevant remote run process Cloud
Connect service connect and socket
connect now what happened to the remote
file copy that is was in development I
don't think that will be ready for 11:3
just because I guess it was suggested to
finish that more recently
okay but it's coming along pretty well I
had some what's the design the design I
don't think there's anything I can point
to but the design was to have it as kind
of like enough value for copy file so
that you could have but how do you
represent the remote hosts it would be
kind of a
a file wrapper and then it would be the
machine name and then : generalizing the
file object to have something that has
also the kind of oh yeah exactly right
okay all right well let's then I think
we're done with this great okay
she touches in okay so the next thing
we're on is is some system processors
right and we have Ian but not Nicolas is
not here yet these probably joins in a
few minutes and we're three minutes
early
yep did you our okay um so what are we
doing here we're looking at
documentation and we're looking at some
more design here um er can you are you
I think there's documentation as well as
design for some of these arguments okay
okay fine by the way one thing I
realized is that we didn't document for
network packet capture stuff we didn't
document any of the properties there
oh you mean the columns in the data set
yep yep I don't really need to another
thing that that we didn't document that
I heard me this morning is the form of
network packet recording that says
record for this number of packets not
this number of time no how do we specify
that that's an excellent question that I
don't think we have adequately figured
out yet well let's look at that for a
second okay okay so that was and also
what did you think about my network
packet traffic during so yeah I mean
it's it's it's a good idea I think that
a lot of people that's like the natural
thing that a lot of people want to use
the one kind of problem we have with its
existence that we can't filter just like
packets that come into and out of the
kernel and so I know I understood I mean
I that's why I said in the documentation
for it that yeah I mean what it's like
is like timing right yeah yeah it's a
more convenient time right and timing
has all kinds of other junk going on as
well why didn't this work
I put that in this morning
what is going on here what is going on
I'm sure I put that in today um and I've
updated this machine multiple times here
and we receive it's at CBS D what was
the function called again network and
network packet traffic during I had a
network packet capture during which I
obsolete it it's not in CVS so ugh okay
let me do the following then um that
means let's see that means it's on maybe
on your local drive somewhere it's on
it's on my other machine hold on a
second let me let me go to that other
machine so that I don't mess this up and
I will send it to myself on this machine
and then commit it here okay because
otherwise we're gonna get that otherwise
that machine actually I'm not sure
what's going to happen because that
machine
somebody needs to deal with us so I
think we need to get hold of Roger and
it's on tree Mac and it is what will
have happened is that it is local to
tree Mac but it has not been pushed back
but if I push back from tree Mac well I
guess it will only what will it do if I
haven't updated a file on tree Mac it
won't it won't push the update will it
no can we get hold of Roger and ask him
marikar like in case I'll give him oh
well I think we I think we have Nikolas
here now so okay well we can get to
assistant processors but I'm concerned
about what happened to that file um and
I also I agree with you that we need
some mechanism for saying capture a
certain number of packets in network
packet recording which suggests that we
might want to use units for the time but
we haven't discussed forcing units for
the time I mean maybe it's more natural
to capture a certain number of packets
in network packet recording yeah I mean
if something that the system in folks
said would be it would be useful to say
you know just give me the next 1000
packets or something like that well okay
so let's let's try and loop back to that
in this meeting um
ah let's see mm-hmm okay all right let's
go back to system processors then um so
this is running in the in the main 5.3
branch it's not true it's still an
external it should be in I mean the four
Brides have been open it will be merged
in but it's don't okay hold on um okay
this should be the external version yes
um okay so what are we doing here so if
I just say system processes I'm gonna
get a whole pile of stuff right
hey hubris all that so now we've also
got what have we got here system
processed data right hey that's the
Association formatted one right which I
think by the way and this in this
documentation should be the first thing
we mentioned because it's some ah and
what is processes processes is processes
that we've launched from within process
link right right um
okay and if I say kill process for one
of these process objects does it work
yes it will kill it as long as it has
permission okay I better not try that it
knows what it's gonna kill here okay try
and mapping it over your process objects
and see what happens
I think I think that is definitively
gonna happen is this this whole web
conference livestream everything's going
to go down just joined maybe he can help
no no not relevant to this hey hey Roger
yes this is a on tree Mac I made some
edits to some files this morning and
okay
Asian tree and I think I must have
forgotten to push them back they see a
thing called Network packet traffic
during and possibly one other one could
you check that out and try and figure
out how to push them back into the into
the tree without editing without
modifying any other files because those
the only ones I will have changed okay
okay yeah Network packet traffic during
just let us know when you've done that
because then we'd like to look at those
files okay thanks yep then we should
compute the median length of function
names over time and see what's happening
within just somebody did that it's
increasing um we've become more
defensive in our function naming other
interesting plot I think would be a
number of functions ending in data over
time yes that would be interesting
because there weren't any in the back in
the day okay this is looking nice so so
this is now okay so we've got PID PID
memory start time did we say we were
gonna put start time there I thought we
were wouldn't start time did we agree to
put start start to him in that position
I don't entirely remember I wasn't sure
I just got the action items today so um
okay does anybody does anybody else know
whether that was supposed to be moved I
don't think we mentioned moving it
anyway okay well I think this is
probably fine as it is right now okay
all right so this is looking
so now um your processes
of your processors running
the list of
processes that are running on your
computer system yes um okay gives a list
of all processes that are running if
we're going to use the parallel
construction on your computer system
okay so if I look here that would be
length of well that's also okay so
system process okay whereas if I say
system process data of all I'll get some
much bigger mess how can i I mean if I'm
not root do I still get to see no I
still only get to see only my processes
right it's platform dependent on Windows
you can see more or less all processes
that are unella vated by default the the
system process data all tries to get as
many processes as the OS will give it on
linux that is most every process on Mac
that's only your processes it's trying
to get everything it can okay all right
so fine so then then what we need to say
here is system processes of all right um
let's see a sorted by PID by default
okay fine system process of all let's
see when we have these lists of
platforms which order do we usually list
them in guys anybody remember if you
look up like some of the machine ID
stuff it probably will have them
enlisted in some order I'll check but I
think it's Windows first still maybe we
should change that the world has changed
I'm afraid sorry
so sad okay so system process data we're
also documenting right so we need to
defeat your eyes that great well this
isn't right I mean gives yeah it's it's
consistently done windows first
everywhere so changing deaths you know
that's gonna we probably should change
it
I mean it's historically interesting but
it probably I mean I don't really know
what the order should be we could do it
alphabetically by system name what about
that that's reversing the order yeah yes
it is most of our customers are still
windows customers just just so you know
it's a good significant majority really
yes based on download download data it's
it's like we just happen to be Mac Mac
person slots in the company fair enough
okay well good for Microsoft okay all
right okay so let's let's sum gives a
data set of information
you
about processes that are running on your
computer system right so they set you
know about your processes
actually one way to say about processes
that you are running on your computer
system that sounds better
you
most of processes that you are running
on your computer system we also have to
say processors are represented
by process object not what it's that
that's the correct thing right by
process object constructs each process
is represented by a by process object
okay okay and by the way process object
better refer back to why is it referring
to input stream and so on anybody
because with the ones you start from
your current session you can read and
write to them okay okay so then this
should refer to system processes here
refer to well that's interesting the
analogous thing here rather inelegantly
would be
you
okay and this now wants to
probably so
does process status work then on on
those
would work on the system processes no
cross the status if I recall returns if
it's running or not and system processes
you will only see the ones that are
running
I see you let's take a look at that okay
so your claim is that if I look at this
four system processes now let's just go
here let's say take system processes
comma five for example and then I say
process status
you
it doesn't work at all no interesting
okay so let's look at what process
status claims that it does um because
that's a little bit surprising that um
you
Oh silly bug okay gives the current
status the external process represented
by the process subject proc okay why
doesn't this work at all that it's
returns if it's running or it's not and
since you're querying by process IDs you
can only get running processes I think
it could work it should just always
return running yeah what I think - I
think we can make that change okay now
what is so if I say why is this
returning process objective zero that's
it incredibly is that what that's the
old way that's what they used to look
like okay but so this so that
documentation should be updated is that
correct yeah I we're waiting Aaron icon
so once we get that icon well this is
this is fine without an icon I think
this is fine with an icon I do not think
this needs an icon it has a great big
thing that says process object right
there it's entertaining to have an icon
but if the icon gives no information I
don't see the point at having like on I
mean if the icon could give the actual
icon for that process that will be knows
that's I think we tried that before it's
pretty difficult to do that in a
consistent way no I don't think we
should do anything and we should have no
icon I know the getting icon can do us
any good here I think it's gonna be I
mean look what's the point we have a you
know 200 processors and they all have
the same icon who cares
makes sense yep I just think you that I
con that sign made for us we can also
just not use that at all but if you're
curious that's what designers but you
sent it in mail or chat or what I
checked sorry
rocket ship okay
you
Oh somebody on the livestream
question about some good a look at their
their results about the data functions
that's to see what they got here
and let's see date introduced this is
arguably in the category of
by the way that bug with the blue but
the things staying blue is really oh
well oh wow yeah that's that's amusing
what was that when just like 80 of them
that that was probably 10 yes I'm
guessing and that was probably when a
bunch of this wolf malphur stuff got put
in the language but it's interesting
there were a few steps up there this is
pre wolf an alpha right these were some
data functions at it before wolf alpha
and I am curious what got added around
okay
well that's interesting that's cute um
[Music]
okay let's let's go back to this um so
so just to confirm icon or no I well I'm
not seeing the I would you sent me the
icon I've no idea how you something up
guys see how you sent me the icon and
that icon is not interesting if I might
say so I mean I just think that icon
there's like a who cares icon is that
really a thing I mean not really
then let's get on with the task object
yeah
just objects to this point have mostly
at icons so it was just for consistency
you
I think we're gonna see so many of these
together let's keep this one on the
shelf
maybe we'll need it later but I think
much more interesting would be is there
any way from the operating system to
retrieve an a you know whatever the
thing would show in the doc for example
yes I think so however you run into the
issue of like all the you know the
system demons don't exactly have dark
icons what does what does whatever that
for dock icon return for a system demon
that's a good question I've never tried
it let me try it see what happens and
one of the problems with getting the
icons back is the amount of time it
takes because if you're converting you
know to 300 icons to something to our
images and Wolfram language that takes
you know several seconds maybe even up
to ten well how do you know I'm like
mean I tried about a year ago Oh doing
this particular thing yeah okay well
okay fair enough but it might be
interesting to have a thing where if we
had what what how do we get information
about a process so we've got you know
given a process object the process
object has queries that you can make of
it right or maybe not hmm interesting so
I mean we could imagine having just like
process status is a function that gives
you you know status of the process the
oh I think sorry the person on the
livestream I can never pronounce the the
SG
Iseman I that's under Houseman oh okay
okay the points out that polyhedron data
was the first data function I think he's
right
yeah I'm also told we have flip Phillips
who's watching with his entire quest Oh
interesting
why did that look um okay so let's go
back here
the
see what we saying we're saying process
object right now the only thing we can
do is ask the status of the process
right
but hmm the possibility would be that we
could ask what what other attributes or
a process should we be able to get we
clearly we can get attributes to a
process because we're seeing them right
here in the know in other words how
would we get on for an individual
process how do I get the system process
data for an individual process you query
it like an association the actual
process object yeah okay well then we
just haven't documented that or did we
document that subsequently I think that
would be a new thing okay but it works
right now it's what you're telling me so
if I go here and I say I take one of
these process objects like this guy here
for the login window um and I just go
there and if I say for example if I say
that of data set does it work not of a
day that's a does it give properties can
I get a properties list there yes okay
very nice okay so we probably want to
treat it just like a data object so like
just like we can say you know what's a
good example I don't know tungsten or
something and we can say you know that
has very standardized properties there
that's great so program are we calling a
programmer but that's what we call it in
the in the actual data set so it's not
programmed name it's just program right
right it's also it's called inside the
objects little box okay so we need
documentation for all these things here
and in the process object so we need to
say yeah in fact we had started
documentation here
and represent both the process that has
okay so then in here we need to go ahead
and document um what's this memory news
sometime used is that supposed to work
I don't think so I never heard of those
I don't think so should that work do you
think it's a good idea or do you think
it's a bad idea would it be in property
I mean can we see the memory for that
object yeah so it's a shortcut it's a
right memory use of object is just that
property well the point is that memory
in use
yeah of a process is what an earth is
this doing well this is what I get for
running the prototype build some it's
probably got some corrupted cache now
okay but memory in use
so the normal memory in use doesn't take
any arguments if I'm not mistaken yeah
that would be a nice generalization of
memory in use to be able to give it an
arbitrary look fascinating okay that is
an incredibly antic oh look at that
disgustingly antiquated object there oh
it's some those dashes come from when it
used to be on two in terminal output so
I took a screenshot also notice you know
we should get that fixed up and I don't
even know why this link object there I
mean I don't know why we're not using
modern uu IDs for link objects that
seems like something we should do
someday it's not critical that certainly
not going to fail the way it is right
now but okay so I claim that memory in
use of a process would be a good thing
to support um okay so let's say memory
in use the process object - so let's try
to support those things and then um then
we can say gives properties of
[Music]
a running of a running external process
because none of those properties are
going to work for a well now they do
work okay um well as long as it's
running yes but it also works for your
sub processes to not what do you mean by
that
sorry I mean for for the processes you
create via start process and the like it
still works
oh I see not just I say even even is
that not running because properties of
external processes
possible properties include and now
we're going to have some table of these
things and the table that we're going to
have presumably should be in the same
order that we give it in the actual
system process data and by the way here
we need to put in I guess we should
include system process data as well and
there and let's let's take a look okay
so this is going to be our list from
system process data so let's say um if
we just take the first row there and
then we say keys of that then that
should give us what is that doing what
an earth is that doing oh come on
um I don't know what that's doing I mean
this is this must be a problem with them
formatting here for I have seen that too
in a different situation today in
today's bill that's it's an issue at
today's build so ok so we can fill these
out I'm not going to fill them all out
here but we've got some this process ID
and by the way that should probably
refer this process object things should
refer to dollar process IDs and it yeah
and dollar process ID should refer to
this whole jazz so that should refer to
parent process ID so I guess we should
refer to system processors here
that's refer to them at the end
you
so an interesting thing that we don't
have is a dollar process which gives the
currently running process right I think
there's a dollar running processes but
it's internal to its internal to process
link because it
it's formats been changing which is I
mean in what I'm suggesting is dollar
process really there's that there's a
question of what is this kernel process
that's running so what I've got is
dollar process ID right but I've got to
go and spelunk in the process list to
get in system processes to find out
properties of my process yeah I mean
obviously that the properties of my
process are actually know and
independent because every one of these
things probably every one of those
things is mapped to something for my
particular process so maybe this is
silly
I mean it's it's like you can you can
have the thing kill itself by getting
dollar process you can say an
alternative to quit would be kill
process dollar process ID mmm-hmm
does that work by the way does kill
process does it do it by process ID now
it does if my process object which was
probably safer and better so you just
don't pass a random integer into it and
get problems yeah I think I agree that
that's asking for trouble
um we're hearing somebody's typing by
the way oh that's me sorry yeah um okay
so let's we're gonna for this list here
we need these and we also need um data
set data set of all properties and
values
and we need um properties list of
available properties okay so let's go
back now um I noticed with link object
link object doesn't refer to we're still
hearing typing by the way um so can
somebody fill these in the rest of these
ah
yeah we can fill in the rest of that
list at another time
I know just implemented memory and
useful for a process object yes okay we
can do that I'll put that code in my you
know well run it by someone who knows
how to program involving language but
that that's the simplistic how I would
do it right um okay
I wish that the chat thing copied
properly it's just a silly silly feature
um okay well then let's document what's
okay we better if we can get that in
let's get it in and we'll I'll write up
tentative version of this okay um
now I know it because that's gonna
require changing memory and use some
time use documentation also so it's not
worry about that right now okay so I'm
gonna just for the sake of having
something here let me just paste this in
and obviously we're gonna use that but
well I'll put that as a as a tentative
there um and you can use that to copy
this in okay um all right that's process
object now what do we have to loop back
to here
we've got we were looking at go ahead
let's look at system processes again for
just a moment let's just see what
results were getting so this is so we
would be looking at the documentation of
system processes right um and system
process data
okay so system processes whose names or
paths contain the string pattern Pat's
fine
pastas which the property has value okay
so we got a list which properties we're
talking about here and and we also are
we going to support something where we
say system process data of all comma and
then a list of properties and including
only those properties do you see what
I'm saying in the output yes that's how
the other forms are implemented they by
default use The Awl form which other
forms so of the ones that take patterns
or rules they operate on the full data
set not the user data set
right um okay so you're saying that
there is if I if I were to document here
system process data of spec comma props
includes only includes in the data set
only the properties is that right that's
what you want only certain properties
what is that what you what what did you
have in mind uh what I had in mind was
the the property filters like filtering
on all of them on the full set of
processes with those filters not the
user one which is already how it works
but now I understand what you mean
return a dataset with only those columns
right yes that's what I mean right I
mean it's not useful I think it might be
useful if what you want to do is get I
mean depending on how long it takes to
get all this stuff I'm not sure it
doesn't take long it's under usually
under a quarter second even on a heavily
although you if you if you were using
this for some kind of system
optimization thing you might want to
call it quite often
then they said only the properties if
the thing is though when it gets the
properties it fetches all of them in
noise and so maybe this is a silly idea
so let's future I think right now I
think that one works better if you just
use the data set tool right and take it
out okay fair enough
should we just ignore this come I'm
gonna leave that own as a future as
possibility okay give us a dataset of
information about processes that you are
running on your computer system gives
gives information about all processes
okay
gives information about processes whose
names or pause
you know I'd be so much faster
there wasn't discrimination against
left-handed people in keyboards only
somebody who's left-handed will
understand that comment nobody else says
I'm left-handed that I'm didn't
understand the common house if you use a
left mouse on node then you can't type
command C command V and so on over
that's why I switch to write a little
mouse I'm left-handed in general but Wow
years I didn't know that okay fair
enough
the um okay okay so I'm ambidextrous
I've used my mouse on the right hand the
eye I'm only I'm right-handed for motor
non fine motor stuff like but anyway um
that was one yeah that was that that was
the sign that Bill Gates was no longer
really paying attention to Microsoft
products was when they stopped working
great for left-handed people that meant
he didn't try them before they went out
or something happened to be left-handed
um okay let's see so okay fine so we
have to say processors are sorted by PID
that's irrelevant I mean that that is
true but that's more relevant for the
list right that we're getting in system
process Dana know in system processes um
okay so now
ah gives
different processors on different
computer systems
user
for the current user
all processes for all users all
processors for all users that does that
include does that not include system
processes of some kind
that includes all processes except
processes that are kernel threads which
you can do nothing to for the Linux the
there are kernel threads that are
treated as processes yes they have PIDs
just like normal processes and I work
very carefully to filter them out
because you cannot touch them in the
slightest so wait a minute what does
that mean that I mean you mean they're
not interesting or they or wouldn't
extreme you can't interact with them
because of the permissions required it's
they belong to the kernel right yeah but
so in the Windows for example that's not
how it works is that correct no in
Windows it's all processes that aren't
elevated more or less
okay but so explain to me these kernel
threads and I mean if I said gosh I want
to see what my kernel is doing would I
want to see if I do PS if I go to a
Linux machine my du PS UI you might see
them I'm not sure I think it depends on
what user you're running ass but I found
it difficult to query them because it
wanted you to be root so oh nice yeah so
I mean if I just do this it'll be it so
in fact what I should be able to do
using our beautiful modern technology is
I should be able to say here I've got a
Linux machine so I should be able to say
remote remote run process Harve is this
right or is this don't do something
totally crazy remote run process at my
luck's machine , this and then it will
ask me to login okay and so that
so you're telling me that in all of this
stuff the K worker and SC and scuzzy
stuff yeah that's Colonel stuff you can
really only get the name for it and not
much else
so does it even have a meaning to things
like memory and use given that it's a
Connell thread not really it's you can't
get more information than really the
name and PID what on earth is this it's
the colonel having an error great okay
that's encouraging that's my file server
okay should I worry about this you could
roll with that you could try running
Symantec import string you I got a nice
data set when I ran it however you have
all this area so I don't know if that'll
work but um okay location so you might
need to get the standard output key oh
yeah right
well maybe it'll be smart enough who
knows um that would be oh it isn't a
string but maybe it maybe it Maps itself
correctly over over an association if it
doesn't it probably should I did
something
hmm okay well anyway it seems very
confused okay though okay but so I'm
coming back to this question about
kernel threads and I don't know whether
we have anybody else on this call who is
a aficionado of such things but it just
seems like if I mean being able to get
that seems useful even if one can't get
all the properties for it yeah I mean it
could be tried but at least for me on
most of the time trying to open their
status file that gives you their info on
them just resulted in you know e perm
you know no permission errors so okay
why don't we say all non kernel
processors for all users is that right
yeah that's correct okay it's just a
mess so I mean conceivably we could use
you know we've got another symbol full
which is even bigger than all and which
we might be able to use if we if we
manage to figure out how to get I'll
just make a note here I'll just do that
and future eyes that note um okay
processors are sorted by a PID by
default well there's no by default we
just say system processes
returns processors sorted by PID right
because that's what he's always gonna do
um okay but now we have to define
so in system processes of prop arrow Val
the following properties can be used
that's the same list that it isn't
getting but yeah yep okay wait a minute
um what we could say here where was that
system with an assets object that's
where I believe you put it okay but then
what we want to do okay so
if we allow that third we're not
allowing this so let's just get rid of
that I think that's just not that's
history let's let's just get rid of that
um following properties can be used
properties can be use to include that
can be used include okay now here's a
question what about supporting things
like greater than in that value so for
example if I want to use find things for
which the time is greater than blah blah
blah
that seems useful to me yeah I think
that's definitely useful and takes a lot
of the craft out of it with having to
construct a pattern I'm not sure how to
implement it but I'm willing to try okay
so I mean that that pattern is used for
like for example in the entity in entity
stores that is a very common pattern so
for example the entity you know element
density arrow take largest
of five should give us the five chemical
elements with the largest density osmium
yes and neptunium was so anyway okay I
didn't know rhenium was so high up there
okay nevermind um
so take largest thing greater than yes
well I mean greater than so there's a
whole lexicon of these things so that
there's some there's a there's a bunch
of them and I don't know exactly how
that support works inside the entity
framework but there is a um I mean
there's also things like nearest to and
so on well as greater than take largest
ah I mean that does yeah that does seem
significantly useful things like take
largest take there because what take
largest would do is give you the largest
by CPU time and so on yeah largest by
memory largest by whatever right yeah
that seems like a highly useful pattern
so what would let's just type what that
would look like
that would be system processes of memory
well of time used this is very nice
actually take largest five that's really
quite nice and that's very it's very
clear it doesn't obfuscate its intent in
the slightest right um okay so now we
properties that can be used include okay
so then we're going to have that same
list from this page which maybe you guys
can put in and it'll be in that same
order there
well let's just what the heck oh no I'm
gonna run out of time here okay so we
got to put these in um great um the only
thing for for path there maybe there are
some contains things as well that are
relevant for that if you're doing it for
the path so for example here I think
there's a contains isn't there a string
contains thing or something that will
green attain skew that's what it does by
default if you just say you know path
yields whatever it returns you know the
process I think that can write so I mean
that that that is also something that
could go on the right hand side there um
okay let's just put in that table here
um okay so that's going to be that table
okay let's look at system process where
is it system process data
okay so this is we now need to copy this
over so this is not the fact that it's
sorted by ID is sort of um interesting
but not totally relevant yeah lets you
know the default sort which I think for
a dataset is kind of nice to know
wouldn't a better default sort be by
time yeah and if I might not that be the
case for both of these I mean generally
the older a process it it is the lower
its ID so I'd say they correlate yeah
right but I mean maybe it should be
sorted by it by with a highest time
first okay so should I add time used as
a property then um so that can be sorted
on yes yes but we have that don't we
that we use a time why isn't that use
the time is time used isn't it yeah it's
time used in time used in user space
correct okay so
so that's okay so use the time that's
fine but the question is should we sort
by user time should we what other people
think about that should we sort these
processes and I mean to me that's the
most useful thing if I if I saw system
process data I want to know what's
taking time on my machine actually what
I really want to know is the percent of
the CPU that's currently being used by
you know the process that's currently
using the largest part of my CPU right
now taking I should be able to get that
how how okay one second I'm fairly sure
it's in the the header I was using on
least on Mac I'll be back in a second
with it it's okay it's a property you
can query well I mean it must be the
Activity Monitor uses something like
that so if that's the case then we've
got another property here and then
that's another thing that should be in
system process data shouldn't it yeah I
think so
as long as it's portable hey question
whether or not that's portable because I
think some activity monitors measure
that over time so it's you know I what
you're saying
so query eight every second or so and
just calculate that out okay so
well I mean we could yeah well what do
you think I think it would be really
nice to sort sort by largest CPU
fraction and we could call it CPU
fraction and just give it as a number
between zero and one
I always seem to have some okay um the
okay
so if we succeed in getting that let's
sort by decreasing so then we would say
returns so processes sorted by
decreasing CPU fraction if we get that
let's put the
a tentative line if we can get it
you
you
you
okay and that
be in this dataset similarly
okay so this is
as data let's see system process data
gives a data set with the following keys
for each process and that that is now
that same list properties um would it be
worth just saying to refer to the
process object page for them I hate that
because you just have to click one more
time I think it'd work rather than every
user who has to click on another page um
okay so in system process data that
properties that can be used any key
anneal of the keys
associated with each process can be used
prop can be a prop can be okay okay so
now if we manage to do this we'll get
this
um in the data set
returned by system process data
processors
sorted by PID
you
okay what happens to the sub process
okay so then I'm gonna have to go in a
few minutes here um
I think we are pretty close to done here
does anybody think there are any major
designers who's left than this
um I think those stuff that could be
changed later to kinda reduce redundancy
and functions like process information
but I don't think anything super precise
information what are you talking about
process what is process information is
that yet another one of these things
wait a minute what is that
did we not look at that well it's listed
right there on the link but it was
another one of those all older functions
built around the old process objects
wait a minute so why does process
information
now I'm confused so process information
I'm really confused here and I think we
just did something stupid so right now
we said the sub value given a process
object you know asking for the sub value
of something or other is equivalent then
to process information with a second
argument yeah
I think we should deprecated
I agree I think querying it like an
association is a lot simpler especially
in maps instead of having to put it
through process information
yeah but then then the question then is
that would mean that we might want to
get if you just have a if you give a
list to process objects to system
process data maybe then it should just
give you an associate a set of the
results for just those processes well
that's that would give one the same
behavior as yeah that seems a useful
thing because then then then you can get
that same now the other question is
whether that whether you can extract the
process object so for example from here
yeah here's an issue so given that I see
this and I filter this and let's say I
find okay that's the process I want to
kill it how do I actually go from the
process system process data to a
killable process object
there's the easiest way would be to type
in the program name so system processes
yeah but there may be multiple probe
that the the easiest way might be to
select so if I look at process object
why wouldn't process object just allow
me to give a PID
because the old way process object used
to be structured is that it took the
internal ID of the spawned process
oh good test as an integer that's what
the zeros been it's been that's the
zeroeth process so I mean clearly one
way to do that that is a little bit
hacky would be to say process object to
PID arrow whatever that's what it's
doing internally it's tracking if it's
internal and specifying a UID or PID
I see so if you just look at full form
of a process object you'll know what I
mean
okay um so if I take this this thing
here
oops one earth is that well I also I
something went wrong here okay
actually I could just say in book form
probably maybe not yeah Marsh plus us
PID okay nice no it keeps some of the
extra process properties there because
they're static and it caches them so
that it doesn't have to query them from
C code every time you ask for stuff
that's pretty static okay but yeah you
could just top out managed process
equals false PID equals 111 and you'd
get the same rendering and everything
right okay but but but this question of
how do you go from the system process
data to the actual process object that's
what I'm concerned about so your point
is that I could actually say process
object a PID and that would work
no it's really a shame that we've had
this sum well let me just think about
that for a second if I do start process
what is it now returning is it now
returning one of these yeah it's
returning one of those with managed
process to true ok well then what's the
compatibility issue I mean unless
somebody I can't imagine somebody has
code I mean can we imagine that somebody
has code that says start process and
they're actually looking at the they
actually think they know what integer
it's going to be because I hope not
because that's going to vary through a
session right right I think that people
are doing that it should be considered
you know you're just wrong private you
know you know yeah it's just wrong I
think so I think process object of a
process ID should work ok and ok so plus
a subject can be created by
okay four processors created by this
this is only true
the processes started by start process
blah blah blah okay so I think we should
say um in here I might might future eyes
this for right now that process object
you
represents the running process external
process with PID on your computer system
yes that's not a hard one I think that
one can you dance okay fine I'll just
put it in then um I have to go to
airport and about two minutes here so I
think we have to wrap up is there
anything else that we know of it'd be
nice to look at this one more time in a
few days um but I think we're in pretty
good shape here anybody can go to any
last points to early next week
one more revealing yeah okay I I think I
agree with you the process information
we should look at deprecating process
information yeah seems kinda moot now so
right it seems like it's a bad way to do
it and another thing we need to check is
that the documentation that we that we
have not confused documentation for what
am i trying to say for the things that
are started by start process and things
that are not we need to make sure that
everything correctly reads through those
all those various functions that make it
clear whether it's gonna work on a non
managed process or a managed process
only um there's a nice very cool
functionality let me um I'm gonna push
it back and - I'll push back that my
changes here
and unfortunately I have to go so see
everybody in due course bye see you
later